hey what's up MKBHD here okay so this
new pixel tablet is really interesting I
got to spend about an hour with it
before this announcement and I've Come
Away both knowing that I don't need one
but really liking it anyway so welcome
to this first Hands-On and first
impressions video also feel free to
check out the pixel fold Impressions
which also has gone live today it's an
eighteen hundred dollar folding phone
from Google pretty crazy I'll link it
below but also make sure to get
subscribed and stay tuned because we
have a video of something a little more
exclusive coming up also from Google
that you probably haven't seen yet but
this tablet this tablet is 499 so really
competitively priced and it basically
has one killer feature you kind of
probably already know where I'm going
with this so design wise it's pretty
simple right pretty basic with this
aluminum enclosure but fully coated in
this soft touch finish that's really
nice it almost doesn't even feel like
metal anymore which is funny it's also
pretty lightweight there's a single
eight megapixel camera on the back and a
power button that doubles as the
fingerprint reader at the corner overall
looks like a pretty normal tablet right
so what's the killer feature is it a
software trick is it the screen is it a
stylus
well you see those four pins down at the
bottom of the tablet right below that
Google logo on the back those are power
and data pins that line up with these
four pins on this dock that's included
in the Box sick so with the power of
magnets this tablet slaps onto the back
and basically becomes a Google Nest Hub
Max more or less so this is the thing
they gave us a teaser of at the last i o
and honestly it's as awesome as it looks
it works great there's enough magnets
that there's like a pretty firm pressure
needed to take the tablet off of the
dock but when you put it back on it
grabs it and holds it firmly in place
and through those pins it instantly
starts charging at 15 watts and connects
to the larger speaker inside the dock so
that's upgraded audio over the tablet's
built-in speakers so a couple things on
this first of all I'm kind of surprised
that we hadn't seen this earlier we have
seen a couple more basic versions of
this there was a Lenovo tablet a while
ago that would like dock into a speaker
but I'm glad to see Google actually
fleshing out this idea and doubling up
on its use they told me something like
80 plus percent of tablet use happens in
the home so for those other 20 when it's
just sitting around your home it makes
sense to just like pop it onto a dock
and now it's this nice polished Nest Hub
display but then also I'm pretty pumped
about the the dock actually being
included in the box but do note it is
the only charger included in the box so
there is a usb-c port on the side of the
tablet but there isn't any like USBC
cable or wall brick to plug straight
into the wall so the only charger is the
dock which is fine but if you have
another USBC cable it will charge via a
wire but then the dock itself it does
not charge via USBC it charges with a
wall wart to this like Barrel charger so
just so you know also theoretically I
guess you could go out and buy a couple
more of these docks and put them in
other places around your home if you
just wanted to I'm not actually sure
what the price of just the dock would be
yet if they're going to sell that
individually I'll ask I'll put a little
update up here if Google's able to
answer by the time I post this video but
it seems like yeah one in the living
room one in the bedroom could be a thing
but then when you pop the tablet onto
the dock and lock it it activates what's
called Hub mode and basically it just
becomes a Google Nest Hub and so it can
do any of the things that a nest Hub
would do it can be a digital photo frame
if you want it to be it can be of course
a smart home control panel which is what
most people want home hub to do there's
also some smart settings in here about
not letting you into all of your other
apps when it is your family's screen
that's why you lock it to enable this
mode but then when you're using it as
your personal tablet you unlock it and
have access to everything oh also they
made this a pretty unique case that has
a wire stand that holds it up like
surprisingly firmly but since it's just
a big circular wire it has enough room
to slap it onto the dock and not be
interrupted there's no extra magnets
needed so I don't have to take the case
off to dock it pretty smart either way
I'm just thinking like this is basically
double pulling up the functionality of
the tablet the nest Hub Max that's on
sale right now is like 230 dollars so
hey if you're gonna spend 500 bucks on a
tablet and you also get that device out
of it it's kind of cool
the rest of the tablet honestly
pretty mid it's just very average like
there's not too much crazy other stuff
going on with the specs I think the the
spec for the display probably tells the
whole story about the rest of the tablet
this is a an 11 inch 60 hertz LCD
display yeah it's 2560 by 1600 which is
pretty solid and very reasonable
brightness for using it around the house
and indoors nothing too crazy 500 nits
it's going to be perfectly fine for
watching videos or movies on the couch
or even handing it to a kid which is
what a lot of people do with tablets
nowadays but it's not trying to compete
at the high end like a workstation High
refresh rate iPad type of thing fun fact
too though you can also get one with a
black bezel they've showed all these
teasers of the ones with white bezels
and I was always commenting on that on
the podcast but turns out the porcelain
color and rose color have white bezels
but the Hazel colored one has black
bezels so you at least have that choice
there is also a tensor G2 chip inside so
the same chip we've had for half a year
in the pixel 7 line there's eight gigs
of RAM and either 128 or 256 gigs of
storage and a 27 watt hour battery which
I believe will translate to right around
7 000 milliamp hours the 8 megapixel
camera on the back it's super basic it
doesn't even have a portrait mode that's
not really the focus of this device the
cameras are more just for being able to
do simple photos and video calls like
you'd find on a nest Hub I do wonder if
you could use this tablet wall docked as
a security camera I'm not sure I didn't
get to try that or find that during my
demo time but I'll definitely be digging
around for that sort of stuff in the
full review but I also said this in the
in the pixel fold Impressions video
which is it's an Android tablet still
and it's been a minute since we've had a
real hit of an Android tablet probably
for Google it's been since the Nexus 7.
and so this one has a pretty clear value
proposition of the killer feature of it
being two devices in one but then you
still have the software question which
is like what are you actually going to
do on this tablet now I think with a
with a middle tier media tablet like
this people probably won't be asking
that question as much but still for me I
just wonder like what about multitasking
what about split screen apps and all the
other things you expect out of a big
screen so I think Google's being smart
about intentionally not starting with
some crazy 800 premium tablet because
that's what people will be asking and
immediately starting to try to do with a
powerful high-end tablet but with this
one you just cover the basics like side
by side split screen multitasking is
here and even optimizing Google's 50
plus apps for tablets they've talked a
big game about this so they have
multi-column layouts and they don't just
look like stretched out smartphone apps
which is good they're really responsive
to the size of the screen so so this
tablet will benefit from all the
improvements that also went into the
eighteen hundred dollar pixel fold which
is pretty cool but yeah I think for a
499 tablet it settles nicely into the
mid-range well actually here we go quick
little update I just got an email back
saying Google will be selling the dock
separately from the tablet if you want
another one for 130 dollars
think about it like that it's pretty
good value 500 bucks for the tablet and
the dock means you get about 370 for the
tablet and 130 for the dock that's
pretty cheap it's pretty good I'm
curious what you guys are thinking let
me know in the comments if you think
you'd be interested in getting one of
these but more importantly what do you
want to see in the full review when we
get one here and test everything because
we're gonna do it okay that's been it
thanks for watching
peace
[Music]